[Music]
anyone here buy Powerball tickets
anybody you can be honest you can say it
doesn't help me if you raise your hand
applause there's a lot of people were
there was one guy up there there it
actually went like this yeah yeah now
it's official Powerball officials said
that two people had the right number to
win the 580 million dollar jackpot two
people yeah so congratulations to the
lucky winners MIT and Ann Romney
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh 580 million just throw it on the pile
yeah over there yeah Mitt Romney is back
in the news you all know this today Mitt
Romney had lunch with President Obama
they had lunch there was an awkward
moment when the bill came and Obama only
offered to pay 47%
it is true that President Obama had
lunch at the White House with Mitt
Romney they were at the White House yeah
there was an awkward moment when Romney
looked around and said so how much do
you want for the place
do you remember the guy you got the Mitt
Romney face tattoo during the election a
couple weeks ago the man who got the MIT
Romney face tattoo is having it removed
now because he says Romney quote has no
dignity then someone explained once you
have a face tattoo you're no longer
allowed to talk about dignity that's off
the table a face tattoo unless it's the
word dignity
very good
pretty proud of yourself aren't you Andy
I don't know why scientists true story
scientists have named a new species of
fish after Bill Clinton that's a true
story yeah
earlier today Hillary Clinton caught the
fish and had it deboned
[Music]
[Applause]
get free puppy never hit crowd was
thrilled when it looked like I was
leaving oh good he's gone you all heard
about Lindsay Lohan latest scrape
yeah Lindsay Lohan was arrested for
repeatedly punching a woman in the face
at a Manhattan nightclub
once he said she only used her fists
because her car wouldn't fit through the
club door she had a ruler ice very
methodical a New York police officer has
become famous after a picture surfaced
of him giving shoes to a homeless man in
Times Square
via police officer said it felt like the
right thing to do and Nicolas Cage said
thanks for the shoes
[Applause]
make here
[Laughter]
this is crazy residents in Zurich
Switzerland voted to allow drive through
sex booths drive through sex booths now
word of the wise do not get confused at
the window and order McNuggets
[Applause]
or maybe that's what you're looking for
[Laughter]
the author of The Hunger Games is coming
out with a new book for young children
that nice yeah it's it's called is
called horton hears a who then murders
it with a crossbow no reason to act that
out and yet I did I couldn't believe
this the mayor of a Serbian village
created a panic when he announced that a
vampire was on the loose that's true
yeah people were running around
screaming in a panic our mayor is an
idiot could that cause a panic